uh real quick I wanna uh uh intern Noah
Ferguson put this together for us on
very short notice
after the Donald Trump [ __ ] grabbing
audio leaked uh we of course immediately
realize that Donald Trump's comments
that no one has more respect for women
than him uh could not possibly be true
here is just a quick summary a quick
compilation of some of trumps uh sexism
and insulting women and just absolute
nuttiness that Noah Ferguson put
together for us I don't want to sound
too much like a chauvinist but when I
come home and dinner's not ready I go
through the roof
okay we get along very well and there's
not a lot of disagreement because
ultimately Ivana does exactly as I tell
her to do I think that putting a wife to
work is a very dangerous thing well you
know a pregnancy is never it's certainly
an inconvenience for a business I don't
think Ivanka would do that inside the
magazine although she does have a very
nice figure
right I've said that if Ivanka weren't
my daughter perhaps I'd be dating her
Rosie O'Donnell is disgusting I mean
both inside and out Rosie's a person
that's very lucky to have her girlfriend
and she better be careful or I'll send
one of my friends over to pick up her
girlfriend why would she stay with Rosie
if she had another choice last week in
Rolling Stone magazine Donald Trump said
the following about you quote look at
that face would anyone vote for that can
you imagine that the face of our next
president
I'll go backstage before a show yes and
everyone's getting dressed and ready and
everything else and you know no men are
anywhere and I'm allowed to go in
because I'm the owner of the pageant and
therefore I'm inspecting it you know I'm
inspecting I want to make sure they're
like every time is good of you very yeah
the dress is everyone okay stay there
with no clue is everybody okay and you
see these incredible looking women she
must be terrific in bed she is terrific
in business you wouldn't want me to say
that I never thought she was
good-looking but I don't I don't think
she's got good skin I don't think she's
got a great face I think her lips are
too big to be honest with you no they
look like too big I say treat women with
respect uh I can say that he's all right
yeah well he did eventually say
eventually in the campaign saying no one
treats women with more respect than
Donald Trump only one of the hundreds
and
hundreds of Lies told by Trump